There are many shows we remember fondly from
our childhoods, from the adventures of the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles to the Saturday
morning cartoons of The Flintstones or The
Jetsons, but arguably the most famous of these
cartoons is Spongebob Squarepants, a show
about an optimistic sea sponge and his daily
life throughout his city of Bikini Bottom.
We all know the same Spongebob Squarepants
in some way or some form.
His popularity translated to a lot of merchandise.
From plushes to lunchboxes and phone cases,
Spongebob is a staple of childhood and modern-day
culture.
While the SCP Foundation’s world is one
where monsters roam and anomalous events affect
millions, Spongebob, and his merchandise,
is also popular within this universe.
The SCP Foundation is most well known for
its protection of normalcy from the most extreme
and dangerous threats.
Anomalies such as SCP-1730 the inter-dimensional
Site 13, SCP-001 When Day Breaks, or SCP-682
the humanity-hating, Hard to Destroy Reptile.
These SCPs pose a direct, obvious threat to
the people of the SCP universe.
A lot of these anomalies have object classes
that clearly state the danger level, along
with their level of containment difficulty:
Keter, Apollyon, Euclid and more.
Safe class anomalies are not commonly thought
of as dangerous, but what about those safe
class anomalies that were specifically made
to be inconspicuously dangerous to humankind?
Today we take a deep dive into one such anomaly.
And we don’t mean scuba diving.
Or…do we?
Anyhow, here is a look at SCP-1808 also known
as the “Spongebob Watches”.
Its containment procedures are almost too
simple, but given it’s a safe class anomaly,
it’s all about the difficulty of putting
it in a box and keeping it in there more than
being about it’s danger level.
There are six instances of SCP-1808, and all
are kept in standard, safe-class anomaly storage
lockers in Safe Wing-C at Site-25.
This is similar to the containment procedures
of SCP-662: The Butler’s Handbell, which
also is a relatively safe anomaly all things
considered.
The containment procedures also mention that
all testing outside of monitored environments
is expressly prohibited.
It begs the question: if this safe-class anomaly
can be kept in simple storage lockers, why
is there such a strict mandate against testing?
What potential danger could SCP-1808 pose
that these restrictions are placed on it?
Well, to properly answer all of your amazingly
inquisitive questions, we need to look back
on the story of how SCP-1808 came into the
Foundation’s possession to begin with.
In early April of 2004, the Foundation was
alerted to an ongoing anomalous item auction
from the anomalous group of interest Mashall,
Carter, and Dark.
Anomalous groups of interest within the SCP
Foundation’s universe are all but rare.
From the malicious Choas Insurgency that works
to harm the Foundation by utilizing anomalies
as weapons, to SCP-610 which uses Yaldaboth
worshipping Sarkic Cults that work to bring
humankind back to a primal way of living,
these groups are known for their use of the
anomalous for executing their plans - and
as we’ve seen time and time again on this
channel - by pretty much any means they deem
necessary.
Let’s just say there’s not many boundaries
set.
Or none.
Let’s go NO boundaries.
moving on.
When it comes to Marshall, Carter, and Dark,
however, they are a bit different from these
groups.
Instead of calling upon the starfish god like
the Fifthists or rebuilding the god of technology
Mekhane like the Church of the Broken God,
Marshall, Carter, and Dark have one motive:
profit.
This group is solely dedicated to selling
and profiting from the anomalous, whether
that be through selling to the highest 1%
of the 1% or contracting their anomalies out
to other anomalous organizations for high
payments, Marshall, Carter, and Dark is in
the world of leveraging the anomalous for
money and as much money as possible.
The SCP Foundation normally has a somewhat
cordial relationship with Marshall, Carter,
and Dark, sometimes even purchasing anomalies
from the group for containment purposes.
However, Marshall, Carter, and Dark often
overstep these boun- boundaries, causing the
SCP Foundation to have to intervene and “steal”
anomalies from them.
The story of SCP-1808 is one of these times
the Foundation had to step in.
An agent of Mobile Task Force Eta-2 ("Buyer
Beware"), Agent Rosser, was working covertly
within the ranks of Marshall, Carter, and
Dark, attaining information that may be needed
for the SCP Foundation’s containment efforts.
Agent Rosser was of course under strict protocols
set forward by the SCP Foundation.
He was to keep them updated with any movements
Marshall, Carter, and Dark may be making,
noting any potential anomalies that may need
containing, and always making sure to be checking-in
every day.
On April 4th, Agent Rosser failed to do his
required check-in, and the Foundation immediately
deployed other “Buyer Beware” MTF Agents
to his last known location - a Marshall, Carter,
and Dark auction house.
The raid commenced, and the SCP Foundation,
having some of the most highly trained and
sophisticated soldiers and agents in the world,
swiftly took the upper hand, restraining and
apprehending members of Marshall, Carter,
and Dark and their potential buyers.
A large-scale search then commenced for Agent
Rosser within the auction house, where he
was found seated behind a curtain with all
six instances of SCP-1808 attached to his
body: one on each of his wrists and ankles,
and two fastened together around his neck.
Agent Rosser was found in a state that could
only be described as pure torment.
He was unrecognizable.
The bones of his fingers and his toes were
so elongated they circled back onto themselves.
The skin of his hands and feet were torn to
shreds from the force of whatever was pulling
at them.
The Foundation-issued boots Agent Rosser wore
were ripped as well to make way for the bones.
And possibly the most ghastly of all, his
teeth had grown out of his mouth, tearing
the skin of his cheeks and jaw.
Could it be that these simple Spongebob watches
were the cause of this torture?
There was no other obvious threat observed
that could possibly be the cause of these
changes to his body.
This made the Foundation suspicious and worried.
What else could be instore for them?
The SCP-1808 file describes the anomaly as
a set of six, yellow plastic wristwatches.
These watches are patterned with green dots
scattered around the watch body along with
images of the famous cartoon character Spongebob
Squarepants.
The first anomalous property of SCP-1808 is
that no matter what mechanical or electronic
parts are removed, the watch still operates
as if it’s perfectly intact.
The most dangerous part of SCP-1808 is when
its placed on a person or animal.
As long as the wearer has limbs and phalanx
bones, SCP-1808’s main anomalous property
will affect them.
Once put on, SCP-1808 can not be removed unless
the person who put it on decides to take it
off.
Once placed, those wearing SCP-1808 will hear
a chime of Spongebob’s famous, or infamous,
chuckle every 15 minutes.
If hearing that wasn’t suffering enough,
SCP-1808’s anomalous property will now begin
to affect the wearer.
After this laugh is heard, the bones in whatever
hand the person is wearing SCP-1808 will begin
to grow in length.
Every 15 minutes as long as SCP-1808 is worn,
these bones will extend about 6 cm until the
watch is removed.
The skin around the bones does not grow, so
once they get long enough, the bones will
tear through and rip the skin to continue
growing.
While there is no blood loss once this happens,
those who have worn SCP-1808 describe the
growing as immensely painful.
These changes do not have to be permanent,
should the person that placed it on the poor
soul who has to suffer these consequences
feel a bit of mercy, they can retract the
adjustment knob of the watch and rotate it
counterclockwise.
Upon doing this, the bones will begin to shrink
back to their original size, and the ripped
and torn skin will anomalously heal back to
its normal state as if SCP-1808 never affected
it.
While the physical harm that SCP-1808 inflicts
on its victims can be reversed, the memory
of the pain and torment the victims went through
will be fully remembered, potentially causing
further psychological torment even when the
watches are removed.
The item’s description also includes the
terrifying note that two instances of SCP-1808
can be placed around a subjects neck, and
instead of lengthening any bones in the neck,
it will instead mercilessly cause the victim’s
teeth to grow.
In the case of Agent Rosser, we now know the
suffering he was going through during his
time as a spy for the SCP Foundation.
Yikes!
The potential danger these watches can pose
if in the wrong hands - no pun intended of
course - can be devastating.
What if an authoritarian government purchased
these anomalies?
The torture SCP-1808 inflicts upon it’s
victims could easily be used to squeeze information
out of a person of interest.
Same goes for the Choas Insurgency, who could
use these anomalies to attack the SCP Foundation
and gain classified information only someone
like a member of the Overseer Command would
know.
These anomalies had to be contained.
The Foundation quickly restrained the Marshall,
Carter, and Dark agent inflicting this horrible
torture on Agent Rosser and forced him to
return Agent Rosser’s deformaties back to
normal and hand over the watches.
Questions circled in the Foundation’s minds.
Why was there no blood despite the amount
of damage on Agent Rosser’s skin?
And why did the Marshall, Carter, and Dark
agents do this to him in the first place?
A Foundation Doctor conducted an interview
with Agent Rosser with hopes to figure it
all out.
The doctor began with a simple statement:
“Kindly summarize the events leading up
to your abduction.”
Rosser answered: “There was nothing crazy
about my abduction.
I went to sleep in my flat and woke up tied
to a table.
Maybe I was drugged, but i’m not sure.”
This confused the doctor.
Normally, when an undercover SCP Foundation
agent is discovered they are not treated with
the relative kindness Agent Rosser was shown.
These groups, especially those such as Marshall,
Carter, and Dark, normally want information,
and will take that by any means necessary.
The doctor continues with his questioning:
“How did Marshall, Carter & Dark come to
discover your identity as a Foundation field
agent?”
Rosser chuckles: “I was never compromised
as an agent.
You see, I don't think they were even aware
I was Foundation.
If they were, they would have called off the
auction and gotten their goods the hell outta
there.”
He goes on to say that he didn’t even tell
his friends or family any details that would
have made them suspicious of his rank in the
Foundation.
Once again, the doctor was extremely confused
by this move on Marshall, Carter, and Dark’s
part.
If they didn’t know Agent Rosser was of
the SCP Foundation, why did they torture him?
The doctor asks this question to Agent Rosser:
“If your identity wasn't compromised, why
were you abducted and tortured?”
Agent Rosser responds “I think it was quality
assurance.
Testing the product, making sure it worked.
Experimenting with it.
And if the raid hadn't happened, they would
have put me on stage and demonstrated it.”
Like the SCP Foundation, Marshall, Carter,
and Dark are more than willing to test out
these anomalies on unwilling subjects.
Perhaps they see their employees like the
SCP Foundation sees the D-Class personnel.
At least the D-Class personnel are death row
inmates - they’re people who committed heinous
crimes, whereas Agent Rosser and his coworkers
were innocent people trying to make a living.
We see how brutal the world of a profit-driven
anomalous group could be with what happened
to Agent Rosser, and one could only imagine
the horrifying torment the former employees
of Marshall, Carter, and Dark may have went
through under this so-called “quality assurance.”
Agent Rosser continues with his story.
He describes the events leading up to the
watches being placed on him.
He drowsily awoke in a dark room strapped
to a table.
He recognized the room he was in as the basement.
He looked to his left and then his right when
his stomach dropped - he wasnt the only one
down there.
Next to him were people he recognized as his
coworkers, strapped to tables like him.
After this realization, his shock turned to
fear as senior members of Marshall, Carter,
and Dark entered the room.
“We are downsizing” one of them said to
the helpless employees.
They were going to use them as guinea pigs
for their twisted testing of their products.
Agent Rosser gets distracted, describing how
much he used to enjoy the Spongebob Squarepants
television show.
He watched it recently and found it funny,
but now, all he could think of is that laugh.
Every fifteen minutes, that laugh signified
more torture, more torment that he had to
be put through.
Now, he can’t imagine watching the show
without thinking of the torment SCP-1808 and
Marshall, Carter, and Dark put him through.
While the physical scars are gone, the mental
ones still awfully remain.
The doctor interviewing him requests that
Agent Rosser stays on the topic of SCP-1808.
The agent apologizes and continues “First
they just strapped the watches to my wrists
and ankles and waited.
After they were sure the things went off every
fifteen minutes, they started twisting the
little knobs,”
He describes that he knew he was definitely
being tested on.
The Marshall, Carter, and Dark senior staff
were observing these tests the entire time,
and even participated.
The experimenters would twist the knobs mercilessly
until the bones in his hands and feet tore
free of the skin and hit the walls of the
basement, only for them to crank them back
and begin the process over again.
You can only imagine how many times they did
this to the agent, for no other purpose but
“quality assurance”.
Agents of the SCP Foundation are trained to
withstand awful torture so that no confidential
or important information is revealed to other
groups of interest or the public.
Agent Rosser, being trained by the Foundation,
would know this training.
He attempted to use his training methods to
resist the torture but it, sadly, wasnt enough.
Agent Rosser states “The pain was from the
inside.
The tips of my fingers were worn off and peeled
back like an old pair of gloves.”
He was one of the lucky ones, though, the
people chained to the tables in the same room
he was in didn’t survive whatever twisted
torture they went through at the hands of
Marshall, Carter, and Dark.
The doctor realizes that part of Agent Rosser’s
story is being over looked and states “When
you were discovered, two of the watches had
been joined together and fastened around your
neck.”
Agent Rosser is silent.
This was clearly the most horrifying part
of this entire ordeal for him.
His silence persists for another minute and
the doctor calls his name “Agent Rosser?”
Rosser shakily begins.
Apparently the Marshall, Carter, and Dark
senior staff weren’t impressed with the
effects of SCP-1808, despite the clear signs
of pain and anguish from Agent Rosser.
They thought it needed to be improved for
a higher sale price.
One of them suggested placing two of the watches
around his throat.
Rosser described how his teeth began to grow:
“My teeth started getting longer, like my
fingers and toes.
But they didn't go straight, they went off
in different directions.
Some went … inside.”
Rosser explains that all he could hear every
time his teeth grew was that infamous Spongebob
laugh.
He goes on to tell the doctor that this torture
impressed the senior staff of Marshall, Carter,
and Dark enough to continue with a sale.
The memory of this makes Agent Rosser ill,
and he vomits before he can even finish the
thought.
The doctor allows Agent Rosser to be dismissed.
Hopefully he was provided with some Class-A
Amnestics to forget this whole ordeal.
The Foundation didn’t contain SCP-3000 and
harvest the Y-909 compound for nothing remember.
The SCP-1808 file also includes a recovered
auction catalogue that Marshall, Carter, and
Dark would have used to describe SCP-1808
to potential buyers.
The description goes on to read: “These
watches are the only products in existence
with such uncanny abilities, and businesses
or individuals wishing to carry out quick,
efficient, and mess-free interrogations would
be remiss in missing this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to acquire them, as would our
patrons with tastes for intimate sessions
of impassioned discomfort.”
The starting bid on SCP-1808: only 14,600
pounds.
Marshall, Carter, and Dark had no issue selling
these watches to those who wanted to inflict
awful torture on their unwilling and unknowing
victims.
And we thought the SCP Foundation was willing
to stomp moral boundaries.
All it took was a little motivation for profits,
and Marshall, Carter, and Dark were shamelessly
off to the races.
For a few rather normal looking Spongebob-themed
watches, SCP-1808 is truly a terrifying anomaly.
Thanks to Agent Rosser’s sacrifice, they
are no longer on wrists and necks and are
now in - Shall we say - better hands with
the Foundation.
In the case of Marshall, Carter and Dark,
they suspended their morality to the point
of testing the anomaly on their own employees.
I guess this goes to show that profits over
people is more than just a scary concept,
even in the world of the SCP Foundation.
Now go check out “How Does the SCP Foundation
Actually Make Money” and “SCP-738 The
Devil’s Deal” for more on anomalous business
transactions that might just cost more than
you can bargain for!